Data and interoperability standards are
the virtually ubiquitous plumbing that underlie
most contemporary health informatics systems and tools.
Given the complexity of healthcare,
it should not be surprising that this is a complicated topic.
So we will divide it into three sections.
In this section, we will first discuss the evolution of
standards and then we will focus on standards for representing health data.
In the next session,
we will discuss how that data is packaged,
transported and shared using interoperability standards developed before fire.
In the third section,
we will cover fire in some detail.
Along the way, I will ask you to use some external web tools and APIs
to explore and better understand these important data standards.
While they may be old,
they're used widely including in the latest fire standard.